the important thing about customer
service in an age of the web and the
Internet is above all be honest and make
expectations realistic don't promise
what you can't deliver don't let your
enthusiasm for your company claimed that
service is better than it is take a
company like Amazon you cannot reach a
human being at amazon well you can but
it's very very hard and yet everybody is
very happy with Amazon's customer
service because Amazon makes it really
clear if you have a problem send us an
email they don't promise that you'll be
able to reach a human operator they do
exactly what they say and that is talk
to us by email I think the most
important thing that a company can do
not just in the customer space but the
employee space is to be completely open
and completely honest don't pretend that
you're doing something that you cannot
do there's an old saying in Silicon
Valley it's not a bug it's a feature and
so a lot of companies say gosh you know
we can't talk to our customers we can
interact with them properly that's
really a problem well that may be a
feature your customers may in fact not
want to interact with you and if you're
just up front with customers that you
can't interact with them then we'll
handle their own customer service
you